Hello,
and welcome
to today's episode.
This is Rawkode Academy.
I am Rawkode.
And today we are taking a look at
Trivy,
an open source vulnerability
scanner amongst other things from the team over
at Aqua Security.
So say hello in the chat. We wanna
know who's here. We wanna get your questions
and have some fun today.
And to guide us on our journey of
Trivy, are going to be joined from
Rory McEwan. Hey, mate. How's it going? Fantastic.
Going well.
Alright. I'm I'm I'm curious because we're both
from Scotland if my accent is gonna change
throughout the session back to my normal original
voice or not. I was thinking that exact
thing. The more I talk to people from
Glasgow especially,
my accent becomes more Glaswegian and harder for
anyone else to understand.
Exactly. I I don't know if you're the
same as me, but, like, during my day
job, I spend a lot of my time
just trying to enunciate more and, like, speak
normal English. So it's gonna be a complete
regression today, I I think. And avoid putting
Britishisms into chat. I had to explain to
my Israeli colleagues that ta is thanks
so many times. It's like, when I say
ta, I mean thanks. Hope you're wondering what
I'm doing.
Yeah.
I don't think I've I've ever really said
task. I think I'm gonna be alright there.
Yeah. Just pop a few hellos up in
the top corner. While I do that, Rory,
do you wanna give yourself a wee introduction
and let everyone know who you are?
Sure. Yep. So hi, Rory. I
work for Aqua Security as a cloud native
security advocate.
My background is security. I've been doing IT
security for about over twenty years now.
And vulnerability scanning, which is one of the
reasons that I'm interested in doing this, is
I've been doing vulnerability scanning for most of
those twenty years. So it's something I've kinda
had the pain of and the and the
interest in for a long time now.
So, yeah, I did pen testing, did a
lot of technical stuff, did a lot of
container hacking.
And I also get involved with the community,
things like CIS benchmarks, help maintain those for
Docker and Kubernetes,
and also participation in Kubernetes security
and CNCF
tag security.
If you're interested in security in general and
cloud native, those are two great places to
get involved with. The meetings are open, anyone
can come along. Just listen. Or if you
wanna participate and help out, then you can
do that as well.
Awesome.
I thought containers couldn't be hacked. Right? Is
that not why we just
Well, my pen testing did say, well,
we can have lots of fun hacking containers.
That was that was great and still is
great fun.
Alright. Okay.
Well, thank you for for sharing all that
with us. It's a pleasure to have you
here today, and I'm I'm looking forward to
playing with Trivy. So for anyone watching who
hasn't tried out Trivy, has never heard the
name Trivy,
what is it that we are looking at
today? Yeah. So what we're looking at Trivy
is actually a project. It was I've been
using this well before I worked for Aqua.
And because back in pen testing days and
if you're in security, one of the things
you need to do is scan things for
missing patches. Right? You look at our container
image. You could look at a virtual machine.
You could look at anywhere and say, is
this missing security fixes? Is this being patched?
And Trivy essentially is the best tool, in
my opinion,
for for scanning containers.
And the reason is it's it's easy. Well,
what we'll see is it's easy to use.
It works well,
and it covers a lot of ground.
Vulnerability scanning in general is kind of this
this you do it anywhere. You might want
to do it on on VMs. You might
want to do it against images. Anything that
has,
like, potentially missing security patches, you need to
have some way of scanning them and checking
them. And it's the kind of thing that
gets seen a lot as a black box.
Right? You know, you you run a scanner,
it puts out some results. But there's surprisingly
amount of nuance and, like, things that can
go wrong or things that you need to
understand. So, hopefully, we can cover some of
that today.
Awesome.
You're gonna
I I I think I've got a I've
got a couple of questions. Right? But Yeah.
Go for What kind of things is Trivy
looking for? What what what's the low hanging
fruit here when we talk about scanning container
images and other things?
So there's a couple of sets of low
hanging fruit because Trivy's got two main angles.
First one is just literally saying, okay. Ah,
you're using an image. You're basing it on
a base image like an Ubuntu image, and,
you know, you haven't updated your your your
base image in the last month. Right? You're
now missing 20 patches.
So what does it gives you that quick
warning of, hey. You know, you're missing 20
things. Super simple. You need to update your
base image, rebuild it. Those will go away.
That's the first thing. But then also, you
get the same thing at your programming language
level. So you're using Ruby. You're using NPM.
And the same deal. Right? You've not updated
your dependencies. It's not something people want to
do. It's a bit of a chore. I
mean, you see it in GitHub. Right? You
see chore update
dependencies.
It is a chore, but this reminds you
and says, hey. Something critical's come out. So
this actually no. You might want to do
this right now. If it's just mediums and
lows, you might say, you know, next next
month, next sprint, whatever.
There's that side of things. And then there's
other thing which Trivy is getting more into
now, which is super useful,
which is scanning all your infrastructure's code stuff.
So scanning your Terraform,
also scanning things like Kubernetes manifests and Docker
files and saying, hey. There are good practices
that you could be doing here. For example,
you should not be running your Docker images
route,
and you are.
Right? Let's let's let's remind you, hey. You
know, you can change this, and you get
rid of that. Start running as a non
root user. So that kind of thing as
well. So it's kind of combo
of different types of things that you can
cover with it.
Okay.
Thank you for that. I I love the
root conversation because I'm gonna throw a question
that, you know, is not directly related to
Trivy, but I know that you've got the
the knowledge to maybe guide me on this.
Yeah. Is it okay for me to have
my process and my container run as root
if I'm using username space mapping on the
host?
That's an interesting question. The if you're using
user namespace mapping, which is fun because it
doesn't work super well in Kubernetes but does
in Docker,
then yes. Because your root user inside the
container isn't actually root. Your root user inside
the container is some high UID. So it's
it's it's only as far as the container
is concerned. And I'm gonna give one small
caveat to that, which is that usernamespaces
in Linux have a bit of a mixed
security history.
There was a great example of this, like,
two or three weeks ago. It was a
CVE twenty twenty two or 185.
How do you know the number of these
things?
Oh, I have a weird memory. CVE numbers
stick and other stuff like, what I had
to eat yesterday? No idea. CVE numbers were
stuff I wrote about a while ago? Yeah.
Easy. I can do that one.
There you go. But so that CV was
really interesting because what it was was it
was a local privilege escalation. So it's gonna
let you get root on the host, but
it needed Linux capability called Capsys admin. Now
usually Capsys admin is like, you're you're already
root. Right? So this isn't super important. However,
Capsus admin inside the username space
also got you access to this vulnerability.
So if you're using username spaces, it it
made this capability available. The code path that
was exploited was visible, and you could suddenly
compromise the host. So the thing about username
spaces is they've got a bit of a
mixed history. They're a nice idea, but there
are some extra tax or things that pop
up if you use them. So in an
ideal world, the best thing to do is
probably run instead of using this space and
don't use and don't use root users. Right?
That's the ultimate. But then, like, I'm giving
the security person's view, and I know that
that's not always practical.
So I I probably the easiest way to
do it is try not to run a
route in general. It's all it's it's the
best option. Or just to run software. I
mean, that's another option. Right? Yeah. Kelsey Hightower's
no code is actually the perfect solution. If
you have no code, you have no vulnerabilities,
and that's just, the perfect option. But if
you do,
unfortunately,
have to run some code, then I mean,
if you think about, like, the way we
used to run apps before containers in the
old days,
most apps didn't run as root. Right? If
you're running an application so so if think
if an app would work okay in that
environment, it should work okay as a non
root container because it's literally the same thing.
It's just you need to have, like, your
Dockerfile that is root for a little while
while it does all the root stuff and
then it switches.
And I know that that's a bit of
extra work, but once you've got it going,
it's like it should be not too bad.
That's the theory anyway.
Awesome. Well, thank you for entertaining my little
segue there. But let's jump back to the
back of the task at hand. Right? So
we're talking about Trivy. You mentioned something that
I thought was really interesting, and it's that
Trivy will prioritize
some of the things that are scanned in
my cluster. And I think that's really important
because
I'm not sure who's using GitHub, but there's
this, like, new feature that I think they
bought from some other developer called dependabot.
And I I have dependabot fatigue now from
the amount of issues and pull request that's
opening across
all of my repositories.
So I've been able to
triage them in a way where something can
tell me what ones are really important and
I can go and look at would be
a really cool tool.
Yeah. It is cool. And I wanna give
you my this is a nontrivy specific, but
but vulnerability scanning thing. And this is one
of those nuances, like one of those things
that I said, hey. This
is, like, something you need to know is
the way that vulnerability,
vulnerabilities are rated. So the the way they
get that critical high, medium, low is essentially,
there's a a thing called CVSS scoring, and
you get a number from zero to 10.
But this is done by an analyst who
doesn't know anything about your environment, and they
don't know anything about how you deploy the
software.
So CVSS scores, especially in container land, can
be a bit you know, you you have
to you can sometimes apply brain and go,
you know what? That's actually not too bad.
The the the the canonical example for me,
there was one in Alpine,
and it basically had a blank password in
ETC shadow.
So, obviously, on a VM, that's super bad
because it means I can just become root.
In a container, it only applied if you
were using PAM. No one uses PAM in
containers. You only have one user usually in
containers, so it was totally irrelevant. But if
you ran a vulnerability scanner on an image,
it said, hey. You've got a 9.8.
You know, drop everything in patch now. But
the reality was it really wasn't drop everything
in patch now because in containers, who cares?
So that's that's where save vulnerability scanning is
one of those things that, like,
you get those numbers and you can get
that fatigue of, like, 20 criticals, 30 criticals.
It can be hard to then to kinda
say,
have you, you know, make more sense of
that? And there's a lot of work going
on in the industry, and various different companies
are looking at this. How do you make
these things more,
like, more targeted?
And Aqua have got stuff, that we do
and other companies got stuff they do to
try and say, you know, are there live
exploits? So you can say, is there a
live exploit for this issue? Okay. Now it's
more serious. Now you really do want to
fix this before bad things happen to your
to your environment. So but it's it's one
of those things. It's it's a funny one.
Okay.
So we've kinda covered that Trivy will scan
my container images. It will scan my Kubernetes
manifest. It can scan my infrastructure's code. It's
looking not just for security vulnerabilities with known
CVEs, but also for best practices and to
guide us.
Where do I run it?
So you can run it in a number
of different places.
You can run it just on a workstation.
That is the one of the reasons I
like Trivy a lot is you basically install
it and run it. There's not a lot
of fancy setup. Some of the container boundary
scanners in the old days used to be,
like, quite complicated. You had to pretend to
be a container registry,
which was awkward,
but Trivy just works. We'll we'll as we'll
see when we get to to running it.
You can also run it in CICD pipelines.
So, obviously, a lot of people will use
GitHub.
And one of the things you can do
with Trivy and as I I was actually
practicing this this morning to make sure I
could remember exactly how to do it,
was you can set up a GitHub action.
And you can say whenever I, you know,
push to this repository or whenever I build
the container image, run a Trivy scan, and
then integrate that with GitHub code scanning and
tell me about and it goes in with
the depend reports, you know, and you'll get
this thing saying, here's all your vulnerabilities.
So there's a couple of different places you
can scan it. You can also integrate it
with container registries.
So if you're using an on prem registry
like Harbor,
you can integrate Trivy with Harbor,
or you can you know? So you can
run it against any container registry as well.
So it's it's pretty flexible in where you
can actually, like, go and target this stuff.
What I like about Trivy is you can
give it to developers,
and when they're writing the code, they can
run scans on their desktops. And then you
when the same scanner later on, and then
you get no surprises. Like, they know what's
coming. Because one of the worst things about
security is you don't tell people about the
problem till it's, like, five steps into the
process, like they're about to deploy live. And
suddenly, it's like, oh, you failed and you
can't deploy.
Much better to tell people in stage one.
You know, when you're writing the code, please
run this thing and remediate these these issues
so you don't get surprised when you're trying
to push to live. Right? And that that
I think that's one of the benefits.
Awesome.
Well, I think we've covered enough ground on
what and why. So shall we Yeah. We
play with it? Yeah. Let's let's install and
have a play and see how it all
works. Alright. Let's see. I have my screen
share here. I have the Trivy documentation,
which I'm sure we will be leveraging today.
And I have the GitHub repository here. So
if anyone doesn't
know how to Google, then you can go
to github.com/aquasecurity/trivywith1v.
I have been typoing it with two v's
all week.
But I'm getting better. I really am. Okay.
So we've got a nice little
Yep. Is this like a coverage map of
some sort? All the things that? Yeah. It's
trying to give you that view I was
talking about of the different things you can
do and where you can scan. So you've
kinda got trivia that the kind of base
there, and then it says, you you can
scan container images. You can scan the file
systems as well, and this is kind of
fun. You can actually scan virtual machines with
Trivy if you feel like it.
So you can use it for scanning your
VM images. And I say that because, like,
there's there's what I'll call traditional vulnerability scanners,
like Nessus
and Nexpose
and,
you know, a lot of older tools that
are in Qualys, obviously.
But you can also use Trivy to do
some of that as well. You can scan
Git repos, so that's the three boxes across
the middle.
And then you can see the types of
things you can scan them for. So you
can scan for vulnerabilities and misconfigurations.
Awesome.
Alright. I'm gonna click on getting started and
hope there's a That's always installed. That's always
a good place to start. Yeah. So we've
we've got an install link.
And then it's all down to what type
of
setup you're using.
I am on a Mac. So You're on
a Mac. So yeah. Go ahead. The Homebrew
one.
See.
Let's make that a bit bigger. Oh, I've
triggered the responsive
design. That's that's all good.
Alright. So we'll let that install in the
background. So it's quite good support here. I
love that when I see Next and NextOS
support. So Yeah. That's pretty cool. I'm a
huge fan of Next. There's a ton of
different ways. And, yeah, there has been a
lot of work done looking at fleshing these
out and, like, you know, it is one
of the challenges with open source. Right? It's
trying to meet everyone where they are per
package. There's so many different package install options
these days. Like, you know, which one are
you gonna be using? It's it's tricky.
Well, yeah, I guess so. I mean, it's
written in Go, is it? Is that is
that I just assumed that because we're, you
know, in the cloud native space. But We're
in cloud native. It's going to be Go.
It is Go. Yes. Absolutely.
Alright. I can see there's a whole bunch
of options for container images, which is great
because I get rate limited from Docker Hub
all the time. So I know. I actually
and this is the thing I was doing
this morning
was I realized how simple it is to
set up a GitHub action to build and
push and also check digital signatures and do
vulnerability scanning in, one action. So I'm I'm
probably gonna move all my images to GitHub
container registry now just for ease of use
because I'm there. More like code is there
anyway.
Yeah. I've started moving all of my stuff
over to GitHub's container registry as well. It
it just works really well. It's it's well
integrated with GitHub actions. So Yeah. That's basically
what I was like. I literally copy pasted
this thing and it worked. I was like,
oh my god. I was expecting at least
an hour of fighting here.
Woo hoo. Well, we have the Trivy CLI,
a whole bunch of subcommands. But before we
dive into that, there is a question from
Joseph in the the chat. So I'll pop
that on the screen. But Joseph is asking,
how does Trivy keep itself updated?
Does it get any latest info from any
server?
Yes. So what we'll see we'll see this
when we run it. Is Trivy will download
a database. So, essentially, what Trivy is doing,
and they actually have a list of all
the sources on the documentation,
is it is pulling security databases for lots
of different Linux distributions.
So it's pulling Alpine, it's pulling Ubuntu, it's
pulling Debian, Red Hat, all the all lots
of distros. And that's how it finds out
vulnerability information. Right? Because these databases online that
are maintained that say which package versions of
which CVEs.
So it has to pull that down. It
also pulls down the theme for, like, NPM
and Ruby gems and things like that.
You can run it offline. You know, if
you have a look at isolated air gapped
environment, we do have instructions for how to
do that. It is obviously more manual because
you can't do that process, but it is
possible. But in general, yeah, there's a database,
basically, and it updates itself.
So does this mean even if my infrastructure
has a relatively old version of Trivy that
it can still always get the latest security
information to do scanning?
Yes.
I I wanna say that there will be
times when database formats get changed, so it's
worth kinda keeping up to date. But in
general, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I I was
running a version of, like, at least two
or three old before this morning when I
updated it.
And, yeah, it's still working fine. So, yes,
it will do. But but, yeah, my caveat
there is I'm sure that we'll get database
changes as time goes on. Alright. You got
a snarky comment from your colleague, and I
speak slower. I made mistakes already.
Sorry.
So this is this is exactly the problem.
Was we do speak people speak quickly. If
you come to Glasgow
and you're not Glaswegian and you go into
Glasgow pub, you will not understand what's going
on. I'm sorry.
This is why. Yeah. When you get that
random tall person that just goes up to
this. Alright. How you doing? Alright. Yep. Alright,
mate.
And then Alright.
No. How'd you go? Okay. Yeah. No. I
was gonna say, yeah, it will just be
like that. So Yeah.
Is I know it's still their best, but
we'll we'll get it under We will our
control.
Okay.
So we got Trivy still alive. We got
all these sub commands. Do you want me
to go back to the get started guide
or should we just Should we do one?
Let let let let's do one to to
to make sure everything's working. So you can
do the the most basic Trivy scan is
to scan an image. So we do Trivy.
So if we have run Trivy and we
then give it the command image,
and then we put in, say, Ubuntu colon
20 dot o four as a really standard
image.
Yeah. That's the And that's like my
of Ubuntu, isn't it? Yeah. That's like that's
the latest LTS.
And you can see that was the thing
I was talking about at the database. There's
it going and getting that database and downloading
it. Okay. So I I've got a question.
I as far as I know, I don't
have the ubuntu image on my machine. In
fact, right now, I don't even have a
Docker daemon running. So I'm assuming it's Trivy.
It's not going through Docker as a proxy
or container d or anything like that. It's
pulling the image itself. It's pulling image and
and checking. So you don't actually necessarily have
to have the image down.
And and that's why it's using the same
URL format
as Docker,
which is it assumes Docker Hub if you
don't tell it anything otherwise.
If you're using that's why you're using Podman,
you might get some funny results,
but in general, you should be alright.
Okay. Well, my font is a little big,
but let's.
Yeah.
There we go. I could I could send
that back in, but why don't we kinda
walk through what what we've got here? So
this will give you a big long list
of it's not too long actually.
And what you can see here is this
is the basic information you're gonna get out.
And what you see at the top is
you'll get a list of the severity of
issues. So we've got 27 mediums, 40 lows,
a total of 67 vulnerabilities.
And then what it's gonna do is give
you the package names, the CVEs,
and then the severity rating
and and where it came from. So why
is it telling you you've got that?
And then you'll also see at the right
hand side, you get a little bit of
a description, you know, what is this CVE.
Now let's be honest.
I'd say
a lot of people probably wouldn't read that
that detailed information of each vulnerability,
but it is there if you want it.
And we also have an AVD link, which
is a vulnerability database we maintain,
which which has some more information.
This image looks alright. It's all low, medium.
There's nothing. Yeah. But the fun thing is,
and this is I picked that image kinda
deliberately.
We've got 67
vulnerabilities
in an image that is as fresh as
possible from Docker Hub. So this is a
Docker official image. This is one of the
maintain supported
things.
Why do we have 67 vulnerabilities?
And this is a weird nuance
of
Debian and Ubuntu.
Debian and Ubuntu both maintain a list of
what's called unfixed vulnerabilities.
So that's things for which there is a
CVE,
but they have not patched it yet.
By default,
all the container vulnerability scanners I've seen will
tell you about those even though you can't
patch them. So even if you got that
image and you did apt update, apt up
upgrade,
it would still come back with 67.
Most people don't want that because they can't
patch it.
So a very useful Trivy tip, this is
my first useful Trivy tip of the day,
is a flag call ignore unfixed.
So if you run that again and probably
before the image name,
just just you might I might work there
or you might just put it before the
image name. I think probably before the image
name.
And you run the same thing again.
Zero. Perfect score. Because in reality, that's what
you should get. Right? Because as far as
what Ubuntu can actually do for you,
that's zero. There's no you know, you've updated
every package, which you'd expect. Right? Because that's
the bang bang up to date image out
out of Docker Hub.
Whether you want which way you want to
run that will depend on your environment.
Old school vuln scanners, like, again, Nessus and
Expos, all the other traditional ones, they don't
show you unfixed issues. In fact, I don't
even think some of them can show you
unfixed issues. So it can be a bit
weird for people. They're like, oh, I've I've
scanned my images and there's all these issues.
Basically, I'd say most of the time you
probably want ignore unfixed.
It's not the default because that's how container
scanners tend to work, but it's worth definitely
adding that generally for Ubuntu and Debian based
images.
Okay. Cool.
Yeah. That works pretty well. We got a
a snarky comment from Russell, but I'm gonna
scan my clustered image because I'm curious. So
Yeah.
G c
a h c r. Oh, I can't type.
Typing hard.
Clustered
v
one.
So is it actually pulling down the the
layers?
Yeah. It's gonna have to pull the layers
because it needs to look inside the layers.
So it's gonna what what it's basically doing
is it it opens up the image and
it says, can I identify an and and
what Linux is running here? And so you
can see actually on the on the output
from the last time, it said detected OS
Ubuntu. So it looks for for essentially files
which indicate you're running Ubuntu or anything else.
What's it?
It's found Debian. Yep. It thinks you're clean,
which if you built that image recently, you
should be.
I haven't built that in a long time.
Oh, I wonder why that's come back clean
then. By the way, it does say error
gets in vulnerability
details, failed to get the vulnerability, failed to
I wonder why that's
I wonder why. I've seen that morning actually
recently, but I don't try it without an
ignore and fix, actually. I'm just curious to
see what happens if you take the ignore
and fix off.
Oh, fine stuff.
So it must
I haven't did any patches since the last
time it was built.
And because in order to fix it, it
it will still that consistently.
I
don't remember. I don't think it's been built
in a while, but then Yeah.
What about scratch images and such? So, yeah,
it can do scratch.
Now, obviously hold on. It can do no.
It can do distroless. Distroless.
And it can do scratch, and this is
where it gets a bit funky. Obviously, scratch
doesn't have any packages, so you're never gonna
get any package, you know, any distro level
stuff because there aren't any distro packages to
check.
What it will still do is it can
look inside Golang binaries,
and this is a fun trick. I'm not
sure if I find the right image to
test this on. It can look inside Golang
binaries because Golang binaries contain,
like, package information.
They're actually built into the image, and Trivy
knows how to unpack that and find what
you're looking for and say, here is the
stuff, the Golang piece, because that's a problem
with scratch images in general is how do
you scan them. Turns out there is a
way of doing it,
which which usually works. I think you probably
could strip that information,
at which point it wouldn't work anymore. But
by default, you can scan inside Golang scratch
images.
Okay. Yeah. Because I can in the Go
ecosystem where statically compiled binaries are are pretty
much the norm. Like, know, the type those
could be bundled with a whole bunch of,
like, lib SSH or lib x and lib
y, which potentially have vulnerabilities. So you're saying
there is
some support for pulling those out and understanding
them, but only if you don't strip all
the GC information. I was gonna say, yeah.
That that's the thing that in my head,
I'm thinking that a security person will probably
tell people to strip that information for security
purposes, at which point your scanner fails. And
there, that comes back to the, like, where
do you scan piece? Because you said before,
like, where can I scan stuff? Well,
if you're doing that, so if you've got,
like, a super hardened deploy process,
then the place to scan is the repository.
So you can scan the GitHub repo before
the thing gets built to find out. And
we can and that's one of the things
Trivy will work with. So Trivy will scan
a GitHub repository directly if you want to
or any did any Git repository. You just
point it at the Git repository, and it
will go and check. Alright. Well, we can
try that in just a moment. We got
another question this time from Jeffrey in the
chat who is asking, if the image has
already been pulled locally, does it still pull
the latest version?
You know, that's a good question. I think
so.
But it's one of those things that I
would need to go and ask someone to
be 100 certain. My my thinking is yes,
but I would need to check. I'm not
sure how how how we would test that.
Is there a flag for that? Let's look.
There's a clear cache.
Clear. Yeah. That that because Trivy does have
a cache. So if you rescan an image
that hasn't changed,
then, for example, if you got a latest
image
and you scan it twice,
it will not it'll it'll it'll actually warn
you about that if you do a latest
image. It'll say, hey. You're doing latest, and
I might not know what latest is. But
you can clear cache. So I said maybe
the way to do it. If you want
to be sure it's definitely pulling,
you do the clear cache, and then we
run the scan.
Alright. Thank you for answering that. Should
we scan a repository?
Yeah. We can scan a repository.
We've got lots of different ways we can
scan. Fun stuff. So, yeah, if you just
pick a a GitHub repo that's got things
in it right and I've got the one
that I can use. I've got the Pulumi
Pulumi repository here. Let's see what happens. And
what it's doing here
What have I got? You can you can
scan it either
in a file or you can scan it
directly on the Internet. So you can just
give it the URL of wherever it lives
in GitHub. Alright. And it'll happily it'll happily
go on to the Internet. So you do
a Trivy repo.
Is the repo scan?
It should be up there. Yeah. I was
I was close to that list, isn't it?
And I was in a little order. I
was getting myself very, very confused. Okay. Yeah.
I was looking at that as well. I
was thinking where is it? Where is
This scam fooling me. Why not?
And then it's HTTPS or
generally do. You could try without it and
see what happens. It might complain. Or just
gonna assume. No. It seems quite happy. Okay.
We're getting it going. So yeah. So it's
it's merely cloning away.
Where does it clone to? It's like It's
it's got cache directory. They've got a cache
directory.
Here we go. Alright.
Let's zoom in a bit more. Unrevelties. Maybe
that's getting too small, though. Yeah.
So you can see how it's identified, like,
specific files inside. So, like, at the top
of each table, it's identified a file and
said, in this file, here's what I'm seeing.
So you've got go some there in method
unknown,
and it's found some stuff in there.
So this is saying that in the JSON
web token go package, there's an access restriction
bypass vulnerability. So if I want to know
what that is, do I just go to
this link? Yeah. You can go to that
you can go to that URL.
See, we've got a nice little kind of
a and what that's gonna do is that's
gonna give you some information about what's affected,
and it's gonna give you some some CVSS
scoring. So that's that CVSS score I talked
about. It's not terrible, but you have to
recognize the person who came up with that
score had no idea how you were using
this package.
So depending on how you use it,
you know, you may or may not have
an accurate rating. Yeah. So it seems to
be that on Red Hat v three, it's
moderate,
but Red Hat v two is nonexistent. What
does how does how do I interpret that?
Yeah.
Here's a fun here's a fun part about
scoring is different
people will rate the same vulnerability
differently.
So there have been cases where
NVD, who is the as an American organization,
the national vulnerability database,
they'll do an analysis, and they'll say it's
rated x.
A vendor may also say, well, we use
this package, but because we use it in
a certain way, we rate it as something
different.
This is where I said about, like, vulnerability
scanning. Everyone thinks it's just a black box,
But when you start getting into it, it's
like, oh, no. There's a whole lot of
weird edge cases to do with how these
things are rated.
And so yeah. That one, I would say
that one that it looks to me like
is Red Hat v three will be a
CVSS v three score.
They may not have done it for version.
So there's different versions of CVSS scoring. There's
v two, which is the older version, and
v three, which should be a bit more
accurate,
but not everything uses it.
And typically, what I found just from, like,
anecdotal
is that v three scores tend to be
a bit higher.
So they they things rated under v three
tend to get rated a bit more seriously,
and that's just to do with how they
classify it.
I I and this will give you my
my controversial CVSS thing. I hate CVSS
because
and I'll explain why. There is a there
is a good reason. It's not just that
I'm a I'm a bad security person.
When
you see a number like 7.5,
right, and you see a big long formula,
you set that line where it says CVSS
3.1
slash something slash something and all that. Yep.
It sounds scientific.
To me, that sounds like it's science, and
it's not science. It's opinion.
That's an analyst's opinion of how exploitable something
is and how serious it is. But when
you see 7.5, I think people think, oh,
it's science. There's there's obviously you know? And
no.
No. It's it's people's opinions. Alright. Okay. Doesn't
mean it's useless. Just means you should take
it with with a grain of salt and
go, this is just someone's opinion of this
vulnerability, not necessarily
the ground fact.
Yeah. I think I'll just continue to stick
my head in the sand when it comes
to security. Yeah. You you you
if you want my other fun,
CVE,
fact is that that you might think that
if there's no CVEs, it means something secure.
Possibly not because some vendors refuse to issue
them. So for example, IBM for their mainframe
line, this is an official policy, so it's
not some hack thing I'm saying. Their official
policy is they do not issue CVEs for
their mainframe line of products. So if anyone
says to you, IBM mainframes are secure because
there's no vulnerabilities, that's just not true. The
only way you get their vulnerability list is
by being a paying customer,
and then we'll give you it.
So another
nuance of the vulnerability scanning world.
Today, we learn.
So Russell is in the chat saying, so
are
not all seven point fives are equal.
Yes. And the thing about it is is
that
that package has a vulnerability.
The question is, does my code use the
code path that has the vulnerability? So, like,
is it exploitable?
And that's a really hard question to answer.
To be honest, it's so hard to answer
that I typically say, you're probably easier just
patching.
Unless you really can't patch or it's gonna
be really bad for you to patch,
honestly, the easiest course of action is patch.
What you could do is you could, like,
go and find the relevant code path,
and you could go and say, does my
does my application actually make use of that?
If no, then put an ignore
on it and and away you go.
For Trivy, actually, I should mention, you can
have a file called dot Trivy ignore,
and you can put CVEs into that file.
So you'd say, for example, I analyze the
CVE. This has nothing to do with me.
It won't affect my code base, and Trivy
will stop reporting it.
So you get rid of that noise out
of your scanning results.
Awesome.
Okay. Let's close this back down, pop over
to our results
the scan. So
it seems to repeat.
Is that the same CV?
Oh, because then a different file. Different files.
Yeah. So what it's doing is it's basically
what it's doing is going opening each file
that looks like it's something it knows about,
scanning the versions, comparing the versions with what
it has in its database, and then just
saying, hey. You know, this one's that many
versions or older. Therefore, it's got these vulnerabilities.
Alright. Cool.
So yeah. So scanning scanning repos is is
is fun as well.
You can also scan obviously, you can scan,
like, a downloaded Git repository.
So you can like if you've got one
local and you don't want to have it
pull it down again, you can just say
I want to scan locally.
That's another option as well. So that was
a Go project we scanned. You said there
was support for other libraries as well. Yeah.
Yeah. There's there's there should be I'm gonna
find it on the
oh, yeah. On that on the on the
doc site, there's actually a list of all
the things they scan for,
and it's getting bigger every version. One of
the things that I think is super important
is we're supporting more and more Linux distributions
and more and more package formats as time
goes by.
Okay. Awesome. How do I scan a local
one? I tried So it's yeah.
It should be Trivy FS.
So Trivy space FS and then just a
path.
So local path that you've got.
Sorry. F s
Fails this. Foxtrot Foxtrot Sierra.
Yeah. Not even I can understand your accent.
I know.
Well, I I'm up at Argyle, so I
probably got the weird kinda like, you know,
Argyle twang to it, I guess, now.
Okay. Something I've noticed between the go one
and then this JavaScript one. So Yeah.
It's not scanning
my code, really. It's scanning the dependencies that
my code has. So it's looking Yeah. At
look at go mod with the go project.
It's looking at
the YARN and NPM, the package dot JSON
for JavaScript.
Guess that's the same across all supported run
time. It's it's about the dependencies that you're
pulling in and giving you insight into where
they are vulnerable.
Yeah. That that's a good really great point.
Yeah. Trivy is not a static analyzer. So
it's not gonna, like, go through your code
and go, oh, you're doing this thing and
you record badly. That's not what it does.
That's not its its its purpose.
Its purpose, yeah, is to look through all
the third party dependencies, that whole supply chain
thing. I'm going, right, you've got this massive
because if you think about about JavaScript,
you know, an NPM project has got this
massive pile of libraries, not just, like, the
initial dependencies,
but the dependencies of the dependencies and all
the way down the tree, and you need
to keep an eye on all of those.
And I think that's it's an ongoing problem
is that that with a lot of ecosystems,
you know, you have to use these these
piles of of libraries and, you know, they
have their own dependencies and it it can
be quite large and quite kind of, like,
complex as time goes by.
It's a scary world we live in with
this stuff for malarkey. It's
yeah. It's tricky. Yeah. It's it's well, you
saw you see
in in in supply chain stuff, we've seen
some scary things recently. Like, there was a
person who they got angry that they weren't
getting paid for their for their for their
efforts.
And so they nuked to their NPM libraries,
pushed new versions over it. They just printed
a lot of garbage text and broke a
whole lot of packages,
including things like Amazon CDK. But they broke
they broke big packages because, obviously, the way
NPM tends to work and everyone depends on
anything else. And, yeah, that's that's scary. That
and that's one malicious maintainer.
And you think, well, he did something really
obvious and really blatant and everyone could see
what he'd done. Someone who's done something more
subtle, you probably wouldn't notice
if they did it, you know, cleverly.
Yeah. I think there was
some package a call from maintainers a couple
of years ago, and then they snuck in
some crypto mining into it when they took
over the package, and nobody knows for months.
Much like months. Because, you know, if
you've got a hundred or a thousand dependencies,
you know, you don't have time to go
through a hundred or a thousand dependencies. No
one does.
But there's not a lot of I've not
seen a lot of take up for services
that provide curated. Like, I've thought some people
have tried as a business model. We'll curate
your packages for you. We'll do that work
and, like, give you a feed that's only
the ones we've checked, but doesn't seem to
take off.
Okay. Let's jump back on to our Yep.
Trivy learning. Trivy, what else we can do?
So we have done we've done image scan.
We've done the docs. Right? You get the
you are the docs. So
Yeah.
This is where I'm I'm hoping who's the
main maintainer. I'm hoping he's not watching, and
I wanna get and Teams, get all the
things I got wrong afterwards.
But hopefully not. So yeah. So we've done
image scan,
and, obviously, we can do file system scan
as well. So we scan directories. We can
scan root FS. So I don't know if
we'll able to do that because it won't
work on a Mac.
But if you have, like, a whole Linux
VM,
you can just say scan root FS, and
and they just point it at the root
of your your virtual machine. And so if
you don't have, like, an ordinary vulnerability scanner,
like, you don't have one of the kind
of traditional scanners, you can use Trivy for
that purpose too, which is great.
Because you'll you'll get good results from that
as well.
But those all basically do the same thing.
Right? They they do what we've just done,
which is that they scan
operating system and they scan programming
language repositories as well.
Okay. I think the thing that I'm really
interested in that I don't think we've taken
a look at yet is you mentioned that
it can scan infrastructure as code and Kubernetes
manifest.
Absolutely. Maybe that's something that we could Yeah.
Let's let's talk about that because that's that's
fun too. So that's the conf option or
config option.
And and what you can do there is
you point to either a directory that has
IC and things like that in it, or
you point it at a a file. So
you point to basically one file, one directory,
and it'll and it'll check those.
Okay. So if you have any or I
can find a repo if we don't. I
have some Kubernetes manifest.
Awesome.
I I don't need to specify the directory
specifically. Right? If I just do a dot,
it'll do subdirection. I think it will. I
wish maybe give it I'll it a directory.
Generally, I just give it directories to arms.
Oh, yeah. It's stuff. Yeah. It found them.
It found them because there you go.
So what it's doing here is it's doing
a set of Kubernetes security checks.
And these are checks that are essentially based
on a thing called Kubernetes pod security standards,
which is something the project Kubernetes project has
come up with to say, here are things
you should do
to improve the security of your manifest.
Okay.
And we can see a variety of ones
in there.
There's our root user, the top one, your
Dockerfile option.
Yep. You've not specified a user in your
Dockerfile.
But it but in in my defense, I
leave this image wide open for people to
intentionally break. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This
is I I mean, I'm gonna honest with
you. Most of my most of my images
don't do that,
typically because I don't do production. You know,
my stuff is all just hacks for my
purposes. If I I I promise I was
a prod developer, I would do these things.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
But yeah. So the the what it's doing
with the Dockerfile is it's checking saying, hey.
You haven't checked that. In Kubernetes, it's then
got a set of checks of things you
can add.
And this is a you you generally in
Kubernetes land, you add these in security context.
K. So the first one here is telling
me that my cluster deployment should set a
low privilege escalation to false.
Yeah. I can explain that one. It's a
it's a weird one. K. Go for it.
Okay. So allow privilege escalation is a Linux
primitive.
And what it does is, say, I've got
a Linux process running,
and it runs as an ordinary user.
It if you have that flag set to
false, it can't get any additional privileges
once it's launched. So you can't have a
container that gets additional privileges over the top
of an existing what it's what it what
it starts with. So for example, if I
had a container and there was a set
UID shell in there, if you try and
ex you try and use that set UID
shell to suddenly become root inside the container,
it'll say no. Go away. You can't do
that.
And that's it's it's one of those things
I think it's a it's a it's an
easy setting.
It will almost never break anything,
and it and it's worth so it's worth
doing. Right? I've never seen a container get
broken by setting that, so it's kind of
a free hardening setting.
And it's one of those ones that I
wished Docker and Kubernetes had set by default,
but they don't. So
I had to switch camera because my room
is very hot and I think my camera
is overheating.
Oh, yeah. I have that because I I
have a Sony z v one and I
it hasn't overheated so far, but it does
does die if I leave it too long.
But, yeah, I have seen a couple that
do overheat.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. We'll stay on this one for
now.
Okay. Let let them cool down. Open the
window.
It's too loud. Like, my my office space
is an an industrial estate with Arctic lorries
driving around big mad. So I'll probably keep
the window closed, but I will turn off
my camera.
Yeah. Let it cool down. Okay. No big
deal. We can use the other camera.
So
this is really cool, and this is showing
me a lot of things that, you know,
like I said, are best practice. I really
should be doing these for my production deployment.
What I'm curious about is, can I just
tell Trivy to make these changes?
It doesn't do that. No. That's that's something
we could look at.
I mean,
yeah. Some of these are quite easy to
set. Some, I would be careful. Some of
them, for example, could break things.
A good example there is you got CPU
requests not specified and memory requests not specified.
So with containers, with Docker or Kubernetes,
you can specify max CPU and memory.
But if you get those especially memory, if
you set it too low, you'll out of
memory, kill the process. Because if you say
to if you say c group limit, you
can have 512 megs of memory. You use
over that. It'll just even kill the whole
thing, which obviously
has impact,
and your process will die. So it's not
something you'd want to set automatically.
Nice.
Yeah. I'm trying to work out what those
resource requests and limits should be is always
a trial.
That yeah. That is the thing with Kubernetes.
I I mean, it's in general problem with
containers is
like, you see why especially if you have
a cluster with maybe ten, fifteen applications,
it makes a lot of sense to limit
resources.
But on the other hand, like, just like
you said, how exactly do you make sure
because you don't want CPU
isn't too bad because it'll just throttle if
you go above what you've said. Memory is
the one that will it'll kill the process.
You don't want to do that.
So yeah.
Okay. We've got a
couple of questions that I'm gonna throw at
you, and then maybe we'll take a look
at the infrastructure
code scanning.
Yep. Yep. Okay. So asks
or oh, that was the
with our live debug. Oh, no. Debug. There
we I
used Trivy to scan for the log four
j vulnerability after fixing the log four j
vulnerability. I rescanned it but still got the
vulnerability and someone mentioned other Java libraries Yeah.
Actually using log four j internally.
So with Java, what it's doing is it's
opening up each of those
package formats and looking inside.
And this is the problem with dependencies.
If you have a dependency,
you don't directly call Log four j, but
one of your dependencies
calls Log four j or a package you've
installed calls Log four j.
And then you have that same problem with,
you know and tracking it down.
I I that's why I can't get, like,
an instant answer is tracking that down could
be difficult. It's really a question of understanding
everything you're including in your image or on
your VM and saying where is it pulling
things from and get access to its manifest.
Trivy should tell you what file it looked
in, though. So it should tell you where
did I find that version of Log four
j. And Log four j is a nightmare
because there's there's many different versions now. All
of them have different horrible set of vulnerabilities.
So yeah. Actually, I I believe it's called
LogForge.
Someone said to me the other day, it's
LogForge. Yeah.
Why would you call your logging package LogForge?
But I've I've been told that's how it's
meant to be pronounced.
Alright. Moving on. I'll I'll I'm not sure
I believe that. But, yeah, that's just what
someone said it back there. I was I
was I was dubious as well. Like, am
I being pranked here to get me to
sit sillyly on stream or something?
I mean,
I guess it's just a name that they
like. I I just assumed it meant log
for Java.
Yeah. Exactly. That's what I thought. I was
thinking it's gotta be that, but apparently not.
One of those weird ones.
Alright.
There you go. Again, today, I'm learning lots
from you. Some of it useful, some of
it not. Yeah. Some of this weird trivia
that I store up and then just like,
just bring us to mind. Yeah. What's the
CVE number for Log four j?
Oh, there were too many. I I I
wanna excuse myself on the basis that there
were literally,
like, six or seven in quick succession.
Every time they patched one. That's one of
the problems with, like, a lot of open
source vulnerabilities.
What you see is that I I will
always call it the blood in the water.
Once someone's done one thing, all these researchers
who are super bright
go, oh, that's an interesting one. We've not
looked there now. Let's all go and, like,
pull that code to pieces. And they did,
and they found, like, literally
half a dozen things. Yep.
I you know, that that's kind of inevitable
because there's so much code
and, you know, good code reviewers are scarce
because it's not an easy skill to learn.
So, you know, it tends to be when
something gets attention suddenly.
Awesome.
Alright. One more question, and then we'll we'll
pop back over to the terminal. I mean,
I guess I could just
we can pop here for a minute. Oh.
Excuse
me while I fix myself.
No. It's decided to
It's just because the seniors did different setup.
That's okay. Yeah. So Russell
now is asking, I'm guessing there is no
easy way to find an exploit of a
CVE for you to test your code against
to see how susceptible it is.
Yeah. Would be too valuable for misuse.
You can do it. So there are exploit
databases.
There's several exploit databases you can search.
The thing out a couple of points I
would say about that. One, it doesn't necessarily
mean the exploit will work on your code.
One of the most important things about exploits
and one of the reasons why certain vulnerabilities
are more serious than others is ease of
exploitation.
If you get something where it's, like, universal,
Log four g is a great example.
Everyone could exploit that because it literally was,
I make the application log
a string
and, boom, I've got an exploit. That's why
it was so dangerous. There were so many
different ways. Other exploits,
you look at them and you go, they're
serious, but you'll never even if you get
some code, try to make it work would
be a nightmare.
So there's that aspect.
The other thing to watch out for and
be very careful of is sometimes
exploit code does not say what it says
it will do.
The people who write this either sometimes they
are actively malicious
and sometimes they just have a funny sense
of humor.
There's a guy called Andy Gill from Glasgow,
and he wrote a thing called Honeypop,
which was proof of concept exploit code that
didn't do that. It just logged it to
him that you'd run his code without reading
it.
And he then wrote a conference talk based
on the idea of how many people ran
his code without reading what it did before
they ran it.
So be very careful when you go looking
into exploit land is all I'll say.
That's quite funny.
Alright.
Cool.
So
infrastructure is code scanning then, Rory. Yeah. So,
yes, we we can do infrastructure code as
well. So this I only have Pulumi code.
So I'm assuming it doesn't do that. So
we're gonna have to find a TerraForm repository.
Right? We are. But, you know, Pulumi is
something I think we should definitely be looking
at adding. Well, I mean, because Pulumi uses,
you know, real programming language, like, you can
do dependency scan and at least you can
be taking a look at the code apps
or the typescript apps or the Python apps,
etcetera.
And I'm guessing the same kind of things
as patterns we have
in Terraform that that we know are bad,
the same thing will apply to Pulumi. Right?
Yeah.
I think they would. You know, like, you
can see someone doing something dangerous, like, I'm
configuring an AWS resource,
and if I run it this way, it's
gonna be open to the world, which is
the kind of thing you can find in
Terraform.
Oh, this
starter kit might be a good one. Unless
you have something I should be cloning there.
I'm telling whether I I have an I
I probably can find a
do we have
oh, wait. There's an example link.
There is actually in the in the Trivy
repository on GitHub
Mhmm. There are some examples.
So it is a directory called
is it called examples or is it called
where is it?
Yep. Those examples and then missed con. Oh,
yeah. That's it. And then there's one called
mixed.
See the directory in there called mixed. Alright.
Let's
clone this down then. Yeah. We can clone
it down. I mean, we can we can
do that. That will that will get us
some stuff as well.
This is, like, one of the things I
always say that I really like about the
move to cloud native, like, as a security
person,
is that this is possible.
If you think about how people configure their
infrastructure,
like, go back to the early days or
my early days, ten, fifteen years ago, it
was manual changes to servers. People would log
in to servers SSH style Yeah. And they
would change things. There was no way it
was very hard to audit that at scale
without physically logging into every server and doing
things. With infrastructure's
code and with people moving to immutable infrastructure,
you have the chance of seeing, I can
scan this before I deploy it so that
I catch the problems before they're in production,
before some bright person finds them and exploits
them and puts me on the latest, you
know, blast of the day on hacker news
or whatever.
Yeah. I guess with everything being so declarative
these days that we have these descriptions that
can just be processed and parsed. Yeah.
And and and the magic then and this
is one of the tough parts for scanners
like Trivy and all the other there's like
a lot of infrastructures code scanners. The challenge
to my mind is keeping up with the
rules.
Mhmm. So the one I know about is
Kubernetes. That's my kind of area. And every
time Kubernetes does a release, they add new
stuff. And therefore, all the IAC scanning tools
have to go back and say, hey. This
version is a good example. There was a
thing called ephemeral containers that got launched in
Kubernetes 01/23.
And now all your I see scanning tools
or your admission controllers have to know about
ephemeral containers. Otherwise, they won't, like, find stuff
properly.
So the the eternal problem of of newness.
Alright. And remain making. Which directory in here
did you say? There's one called mixed mixed
definitely has something in it. I I looked.
There was some Terraform files in there.
In configs. Yeah. That was it. Yeah. There's
a t f files. There's couple t f
files there. So Trivy
config.
I've done yeah.
If you're in the directory, you should yay.
Page it. Okay. So it
vendor Docker file.
Yep.
And there And CloudFormation.
So we're doing CloudFormation as well. Oh, there
we go. Yeah. Okay. I was trying to
work out what that YAML was. I was
like, how is this, like, a cross
play or something, but it's quite it says
right there is Cloud information. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
So it detects different types. And this, again,
this is one of the things that the
Trivy is expanding over time. So recently,
we got a couple of of of great
guys into the team who wrote TF sec,
which is a Terraform security tool, and that's
integrated now into Trivy, which is fantastic. So
now you can just run Trivy, and it
will, you know, do this TFsec stuff as
well, which is great.
So we can see here Yeah. That it's
complaining
that our s
buckets are public.
Yeah. Right. So that that's the kind of
thing and this is, again, this is another
one where,
like, you do have to think about responses
from these scanners. You can't take them blind
because it may be that your s three
bucket's meant to be public. Yep. You might
be hosting public documents there,
but you might not.
And so all this the scanning tool can
do is it can say this stuff looks
you know, here's your investigation.
And in general, this is a challenge for
security people because sometimes
auditors will use these tools,
and auditors don't always understand the technical details
of what they're scanning. And this but but
I don't think there's a good way to
get away from that. Apart from if I
was doing this work, I would run the
scanners myself and have an answer for their
questions.
So if you know if says, hey. This
this s three is public, go, yep. That
one's allowed. It's holds the stuff here. We
know what's in it. It's a static website.
It's supposed to be Exactly. It it it's
our t's and c's that we give to
all our customers or something. You know, it's
it's public docs.
Yeah. But it's important to get these messages.
I actually recorded a video of the Polyvio
channel just last week talking about the three
major exploits in the last two years, and
all of them are related to ACL on
a s three bucket. Yep. Hundreds
of thousands of private documents in the Ghana
government
and all the citizens was released to the
public.
Game companies are seem to be bad for
this as well. Game companies only can do
a left, right, and center via s three
buckets. It it doesn't surprise me because I
like, a lot of enterprises now,
it seems like their entire IT infrastructure is
in the cloud. Yeah. And I go back
to my old corporate security days when everything
was hidden behind the corporate firewall, so at
least you couldn't easily see it. I mean,
it still was hackable, but you had to
get past that firewall.
And back then, those I always called the
networks warm smarties.
So they're crunchy outside, they're all gooey and
soft on the inside.
And now everyone's put all that stuff straight
on the Internet.
If anyone from non UK is watching, warm
m and m would be the international
equivalent of warm smarty.
I call them warm smarty networks. But now
everyone puts that stuff straight in in AWS,
and then you're right there on the Internet.
If you make that same one mistake, you
know, you don't understand something. You've got a
line in a YAML file wrong, and suddenly
it's odd here, some bad person has found
your stuff. And Yeah. But this maybe
I I I said I would say there's
just security, but I'm seeing this massive push
towards zero trust, but we're still so early
in education
of zero trust to develop Yep. That that
there was weirdly, this is like, you know,
they all see what is old is new
again.
So in literally 02/2002, when I was starting
in security, there was a thing called the
Jericho Forum in The UK who pushed something
called deperemeterization,
which is the exact same thing as zero
trust.
It was removed the firewalls, put everything on
the Internet because you have to be able
to trust things.
Smart's not global. I I think they're not
global. I think I don't I think Americans
don't have smarties.
I believe it's horrible to say, but but
I believe it's true.
So, yeah, zero trust is my my business.
Today. Right? Yeah. Zero trust is cool if
you're doing it right. Like, if ever I
mean, yes. They're right in theory. Right? It's
one of those things. In theory, they're right.
Every system should stand alone. It shouldn't trust
anyone. It shouldn't say I want a trusted
network. It should just be
in reality.
That's not how things work. People make mistakes.
They stand up demo systems. They stand up
test systems. They don't always patch or secure.
And putting those all on the Internet sounds
like a kind of dangerous idea to me.
Luckily,
I'm not in that world, so I'm very
happy not to be in that world. I
I guess that's your option. Because you put
everything on the Internet, and you learn how
to secure it properly, and you try to
keep up with modern trends, or you stick
Bastion Box or VPN.
And Yep.
But then you still got lateral movement beyond
those parameters. So, like Yeah. Is
do you need to do both? I I
I would. I I have this I have
this concept. I I I did when this
talk with a guy from GCHQ,
and he had this concept. I won't use
the real his the way he called it
because it's a bit rude on stream. I
call it mess up tolerance.
He called it something else to up tolerance.
And the idea is, like, you don't want
to have a mess up tolerance of one
where if one bad thing goes wrong, your
entire network's stuffed.
And that to my mind, if you put
things on the Internet, like Kubernetes API servers,
there are 900,000
Kubernetes API servers directly connected to the Internet.
One bad day, you may lose a set
of creds, you make a mistake with your
RBAC,
and your entire cluster could get compromised, and
all the hosts and all the workloads get
go down with it. That's a messed up
tolerance of one. To my mind, put it
behind the bastion box, then at least two
things have to go wrong. Someone has access
to your bastion, and you have to make
a mess up with Kubernetes.
And you saw that, like, make your life
that little bit less painful because everyone makes
mistakes. Right? I make mistakes. You make mistakes.
We all make mistakes.
I've never made a mistake, Rory.
No. Me neither. My my my mistake is
perfect.
And don't go and look at my repositories
and look at the ones I've enabled VON
scanning on, and you won't see all the
hundreds of issues that I haven't patched.
Cool.
Well, let's go back to the important topic
for today. Yeah. Thomas Laff has told us
that they have Smarties in Croatia.
Oh, well, that's good. However, Russell has done
some research.
Good to find you there. But the term
Smarties in The US is used for what
we call refreshers.
Good grief.
That's a terrible one. That you could very
badly wrong there. So the question I've got
is, Thomas Lav, what is a smarty in
Croatia? Because maybe we're making too many assumptions.
That's true. We're assuming. So a smarty is
is a nice crunchy candy shell
with
chocolate inside. Good chocolate, not American chocolate.
Alright.
We we we
on an hour. No, Rory. And I'm I'm
having fun. I I could just sit here
do this all day. But
do you want to show us the GitHub
actions workflow or would you rather leave that
for another session? You want to? Let let's
quickly. I'll show you now because I I'm
gonna do a blog on this because I
I just looked at this today,
and I was like, this worked really well,
and I was super happy with it. So
I was I'm I but there will be
a blog that that goes into this some
more detail. I'll try and get out the
week or two, and I'll I'll tweet it
out. Yeah. Just get a link over to
me. I'll drop it in the description as
well for anyone watching after the fact. Yeah.
So we'll get that sorted out. I wanna
I wanna show you our our let me
get my window, and it's this window here.
So let's share that.
So that should pop up now. And this
is a this is a repository I have
for a little Ruby on Rails project I
wrote,
which is a little thing I did for
attack trees. It's not super important.
But what I've got here let me just
make this a bit bigger. Thank you. Is
I got the the basic
container build
GitHub action,
which is this one here.
And this actually worked really well. I was
super impressed by this just worked when I
built it.
And what this does is it builds up
a a docker image and pushes it to
GitHub, put to GitHub container repo. The other
really cool thing it did, and I did
literally didn't know until this morning, is it
uses cosign.
And cosign is
yeah. I was I was so impressed. So
cosign for anyone who's not seen it is
a digital signing tool. Essentially, will essentially put
digital signature on your container image, and anyone
who used your container image later can verify
that signature and make sure that the image
has not been tampered with since it was
pulled down from the registry. This is a
really great thing.
And in general, signing has been, like, a
awkward to use thing, so it never really
gets traction because it's hard. It's painful. You
have to manage keys.
This just worked. Like, I installed the action,
and it worked. It was magic. I was
like, wow. So impressed. But so it did
all this, and you see it's doing docker
build, and it's pushing the image.
And then what I did down the bottom
here, you'll see at the very bottom here,
I've got run Trivy.
So this is from our we have a
a trivy action,
and you see it just have a users,
so it's gonna use the trivy action,
and it's gonna tell it what image I
really should make this parameters and I will,
but right now, just named the image as
I was I was doing it quickly.
We used an output format called Serif. Now
Serif is just a way of, like, marking
up your vulnerabilities,
gave it a name, and that's just the
default name. Then we did this cool thing
here right down the bottom, which is we
upload the the results to GitHub security. So
GitHub has a security tab on every repo,
and you can get scanners to integrate with
that. This will work on any public repository.
I think if you use a private one,
you have to be like an enterprise customer.
But if your repo is public, it will
work. And it will actually upload it into
into GitHub
as a result,
which is really cool.
The only trick, and I will put this
in the blog, that I need that I
got wrong, like, three or four times. You
can see all my failed runs. You look
in this repository.
Is you need to give it security events
right
permission.
So there's a little permission to add there
into the permission section that wasn't there in
the default action that lets upload the SARIF
file. Are these permissions things new? I've I've
honestly, I've never seen those before to get
back And I hadn't either, which is why
I was like so I was doing my
u the usual thing. Right? I errored out
in the action, and I went and googled
that exact error message.
And some, like, playing around and where exactly
do I put this thing later, I worked
it. That's where you put it. So you
put it inside the build. These ones were
already there.
So these ones were part of the base,
like, the the one that GitHub gave me.
Mhmm. And then I just added that line
there, security events. Right?
And the end result is is that that
it will do that. It will build the
image, and then you go into the security
tab,
and what you'll see is I have 963
code scanning results.
I didn't turn on ignore unfixed yet. I
will turn on ignore unfixed, and that will
drop that number down. But, basically, what you
can see there is you can see all
of Trivy's output essentially in there. You can
see all the different CVs. Yep.
So that's really nice integration. Right? If you
are if you wanna use it as part
of your CICD,
just plop it in an action,
have it whenever you push or whenever you
build your images,
and it'll keep you up to date and
let you know, hey. You've got, like you
know, you need to go rebuild your base
image or something or you need to go
and upgrade your gem file. In my case,
it'll be a gem file
and or a YARM mock file. There's gonna
be stuff in there for all of those.
Sweet. Awesome. I like that. That's very cool.
I know. I was like it's one of
those things where I thought, I'm just gonna
try and get this working so I can
talk about it. Didn't expect to actually get
it working this morning. And I was like,
oh, this actually worked. I'm I'm pleasantly surprised.
Well, I'm I'm I'm really glad that I
have walked well, I will be walking away
from today's session. Understand the Trivy and how
to integrate it. But permissions and a workflow.
There we go. That's the value add for
me today. Because I Yeah. That was that
was something I learned today as well. It's
like, never a bad day when you learn
something new and I learned about permissions and
GitHub actions. I'm then motivated to go play
with it some more. And everyone should also
be cosigning all the things. Right? Yes. Cosign
is so cool.
And I yeah. Cosign
container images. You can cosign binaries as well,
and then you can integrate. So a good
thing you can do now, again, come back
to Kubernetes,
is you can put an admission controller onto
your clusters that will check those signatures.
So it'll say Right. Am I only getting
the same images in my cluster? So if
you have a prod cluster, you can start
sending your production images, and that stops people,
like, using images you're not expecting. Right? Because
it's always a problem. Someone might start running
an image from Docker Hub. Those things could
be anything in large part. So you only
want trusted images. So you can start trying
to do that. And I I I think
we'll see more support for cosign this year
as time goes on.
I know that the RubyGems folks are discussing
adding it for RubyGems packages.
So the the there's an RFC in for,
like, actually signing the RubyGems. So, hopefully, we'll
see more of that as well. Awesome.
If you get anything else to share on
your screen share, will pop us back over
to the I will pop pop us back
over. Yeah. Cool.
Alright. Well, thank you for joining me today
sharing Trivy with everyone. And not just Trivy,
just your general knowledge across the board is
always wonderful to have a a conversation. And,
I mean, Smarties was pretty important, but there
was lots of other good stuff in there
too. But we'll focus on the Smarties. I
mean, we could tagline for the for the
episode there. We talked about Smarties. And I
hope Harry is still with us and still
understanding most of what we say. I hope
he's Oh, I'm I'm probably gonna get my
slowdown afterwards in Teams. Alright.
We got a great stream from Russell. Thanks,
mate.
Any last words, Rory, before I let you
get back to your day?
Nope. Nope. If anyone's got any questions, I
will say, Racine there is on my is
my Twitter handle. It's also my GitHub handle.
Feel free to just ping me or drop
an email. Either way, I'm easy to find
online and always happy to try and answer
questions.
Awesome. Well, thank you again for joining us.
Have a great day. I hope to see
you soon. Maybe at KubeCon Valencia, and Yeah.
Till then,
I don't know. Stay healthy. Is that the
pandemic? Wait. You're saying things off now? Yeah.
Sounds possible.
Alright. I'll speak to you later. Thanks. Cool.
Cheers.